[Music]
you are so good at coming across and
you've been called one of the scariest
guys on television such an intimidating
character and I'm realizing that I've
actually seen scenes where you're
smiling and you still look intimidating
even when you're smiling you there's
like a bit of security sorry how do you
pull that off I don't know I'd no idea I
think it's like Slavic fat pads and
eyebrows that system you think it's the
eyebrows I think it's mostly the
eyebrows because I am it's not it's not
that I know you look mad at me we're
just having a nice conversation we know
each other and work friendly and you're
I feel like you're mad at me because of
your eyebrow I don't understand either
my entire life they're just that way to
keep the Sun out of mine Neanderthal
eyes no channel rain yeah yeah yeah yeah
I am lacerated because I cannot
intimidate anybody if I try I don't have
this nothing I do with this says I'm a
badass you know but you can walk out
here and your natural resting face is
you could kill me maybe if you cut the
hair a little bit
not that you would want to appear to be
a violent person yeah if you lost a
little bit of the rise in the front you
might look a little ight everyone in
this crowd and everyone watching right
now they just will not accept it
I can't believe I overstep that yeah
yeah you're gonna get a lot of hate mail
like you like anyone writes letters
anymore
what are they actually fighting for that
your hair is terrifying
yeah is that what they're saying yeah I
got a buzz cut I think they're fighting
because they would be terrified of you
if you cut your hair but you actually do
have a very intimidating face Petain
potential you look great get camera one
and just push it in and lose the hair
completely just get all the way in there
put your eyebrows down a little bit what
do you mean put them down a little bit
don't go down yeah look
oh that's a Carrie Donovan I didn't get
ya and it would kill you with his potato
shovel
you